Jerry yeah
very
Hey
hello walls rocky come on no ash love
Nellie's this camera guy
[Music]
yes like it's like now um you know this
is work in progress both yeah now he's
not episode with these these situations
are gonna crop up more frequently you
know because the fact that he needs to
work on his life and address things
while still uncomfortable is you know
just sort of a mode of being for him
yeah Raphael in one I think it was like
either a reddit AMA or an interview he
said you know someone was asking all
right this is what season 1 is about
what season 2 is about and he put it
really awesomely and really succinctly
he says I guess season 2 is about
someone trying to fight their way out of
a rut and the rut fighting back
yeah and this is a geeky yeah that's a
good way to put I think that's a
brilliant way to put season two because
with Bojack it's like basically I mean
and it's actually put really [ __ ]
well because so Bojack at the end of
season one he lands his dream job
the Mayans his dream role of playing
Secretariat in a biopic and Secretariat
in the universe of the show is voiced by
John Krasinski really well I feel like
this is like John Krasinski doing his
guests like he's doing his most like
showing off his ass acting muscles as
much as he did when he like did his bit
for um his his David Foster Wallace
movie Oh brief interviews with with
hideous men which he dfw but II have to
have you sounds like sounds like it
would be a final a file format extension
David post was that the effort so dr.
zimsky is secretary the secretary Oh is
was an athlete a racehorse in the 70s
who was discovered to be betting on it
was like a very like a very damaged and
a screwed-up character like Bojack but
who was such a big celebrity in the 70s
it was a big deal and and ended up
committing suicide when he was kind of
disgraced and Bojack like Secretary was
bojack's childhood hero one Bojack was a
little kid in abusive household so he's
playing Secretariat in a
he's playing Secretariat in and kind of
like an Oscar baby biopic and so there's
a bit where Bojack and the director of
the movie plate who's uh Kelsey Jennings
voiced by Maria Bamford like bojam Rhea
Bamford
yeah that's Maria Bamford but she's sick
Murray papers are gonna not speak in
that really squeaky register yeah Maria
Bamford can change her voice really
really well yes seriously yeah so yeah
so Maria Bamford Maria Bamford director
of the secretary of movie
Bojack ends up getting her to cuz the
movie gets like shanghaied by the studio
and like turned it to this like really
chintzy not great like feel-good movie
that kind of adds up to nothing when the
real movie that was planned was gonna be
dark and gritty and show the the
Secretary of warts and all
Bojack gets kelsey Jannings to go sneak
into the Nixon Library to steal a shot
because Jennings gets fired and her
replacement is this Dole tea and he's
you you can't help but hate him but he's
so nice but you you hate him and his
he's this catfish named Abe whose voice
really well by Gary Marshall who says
this [ __ ]
yeah it's Gary Marshall oh wow every
time I say who voices a character you
were just gonna say oh [ __ ] I am unless
you yeah it's like Todd was voiced by
Gary Marshall oh [ __ ] this is a great
freshman ya know um
so Abe the catfish he ends up ate the
catfish is just this this big kind of
doofus II guy who you know he's just
gonna kind of toe the line of the studio
is just really mediocre he's just a
really mediocre director and when he he
accidentally gets called on it he gets
so vehemently defensive man yes it's not
Casablanca it's not like a rain in Gaza
fly
it's like that movies aren't even made
yeah it's like so and it's hilarious
Holly bojay gets sucked into the smoke
bomb because because Abe said Abe shrugs
off the fact that the movies been
changed and gutted so much is this so
we're not making Casablanca and then
Bojack makes a joke back it's like yeah
you know the movie sucks and Abe sing
you sing the movie [ __ ] and bojack's
like well you you said yourself we're
not meeting in Casablanca and Nate says
yeah because that movies already been
made perfectly seriously
and so you realize what kind of yeah you
realize this guy is this guy is a dolt
and he's a really defensive dolt with a
hair-trigger yeah who's now going to
make your life [ __ ] alive shitty doing
to take after take after take because
initially he does one take think it's a
bad perform gets like you know a subpar
first take and just keeps rolling and
moving on and so and Bhoja commented on
it like are you sure you don't want to
get another take and so then Abe starts
[ __ ] with Bojack by making him do
take after take after take and he
happens to make Bojack do take after
take after take up the line I'm tired of
running in circles and that's that's
kinda like this moment in the yeah
that's like I wanna say episode 9 10 9
or 10 9 10 and it's the what do you
realize like yeah the the rut fought
back and while you weren't looking the
rut one yeah you thought Bojack thought
alright I'm going to do all this [ __ ]
and get myself out of this horrible
personal hole oh my god I'm still back
in the same mess I've always been in it
might still the hole is a different
corner of the hole yeah it's like my my
situational trappings have changed but
everything about what this means and
where I'm at and how I feel and where my
brain is is exactly the same well
there's that conversation they have
later on about you know it's like if you
had done that broadly Broadway play
would you be happy for a little while or
had secretary turned out to be the movie
you wanted would you already ask for a
little while but then but then you know
eventually I just end up right back here
again you know when the when the shine
wears off and I think that's brilliant
because it's like buzz
that's you know this is a show very
poignant like you know well it's
interesting because it's like the way TV
works is there has to be a formula so
the same thing basically the same broad
thing has to happen over and over again
but the way everything looks has to be
different yeah you know like your
standard sitcom the status quo has to
always get reasserted at the end of
every episode in the long view certain
continuity things can change but
basically it almost feels flipped in
Bojack horseman where it's like it
almost feels like you know the show has
changed and what's been going on has
changed and the formula has changed but
as a cruel joke to Bojack as much as
he's trying to change he hasn't he's
been still stuck in the same like pit of
tar that he was trying to run out of to
begin with yeah exactly
he's just been spinning his wheels and
it comes as kind of us you know while
you weren't looking it comes as kind of
a surprise you you kind of see alright
so there's this different sort of
tension in BO types are that's building
up but then it's like this this cruel
joke it's like you actually you you
thought alright I'm going to it's like
you think all right I'm going to I'm
going to crawl out of this hole so I
don't die in here but joke's on you
you've actually been dead and in hell
this whole time so sinister way to
something yeah it's like zooming in on
bojack's facing I'm tired of running in
circles and getting more and more sad in
desperate and morose when it hits in and
Will Arnett does a brilliant job of boys
and really doesn't know jack he brings
so much to that character well and it
seems like the more he does that thing
that the you know that the more he's on
set the more he's doing the thing he
always wanted like there are some
significant character breakthroughs that
happen during takes or in the effort to
get takes you know it's almost like the
very thing he thought he wanted is
actually becoming very revealing as to
what he's missing yeah what he's still
missing and then that and I think like
escaping the the movie cuz it's like no
one will come such a frustration he
tries to escape being
doing this [ __ ] up movie and so he
goes to hit up the biggest loose threat
that was opened up by the end of the
first the first season yeah so oh man so
Bo Jack when he was a young aspiring
stand-up comic and trying to trying to
break into acting and everything like
that he was friends with her his ass who
ends up becoming the runner earth is
your business he met Stanley Tucci's
character herb because as who is his
former best friend who was also the
former showrunner of the sitcom that
made Bojack who he was that gave him all
the celebrity and his money and
basically froze him in time as a stunted
adolescent that never grew and and
became a bad human being so his best
friends with herb and herbs then
girlfriend Olivia Wilde's character a
deer named Charlotte who hung around for
events and was like a really close
friend and said some stuff where it's
like she very clearly saw deeply into
who Bojack was as a person and ends up
going to move to Maine and Bojack hasn't
seen the present timeline that the show
Bojack hasn't seen her in about thirty
years yeah he meets Charlotte this is
like basically what I was saying it's
like oh man next season like herbs gonna
die cuz he has cancer in the end of the
first season herbs gonna die beau Jeff's
gonna be at the funeral and Charlotte's
gonna be there and they're going to like
meet again for the first time in X
number of decades sure enough that
happens and where it goes from there is
as so it's like bojayá ends up going to
Charlotte's out living in New Mexico
Bojack goes to hit her up in New Mexico
cuz you know she says hey if you're ever
in the state drop me a line Bojack goes
and you know they're at the end of the
eleventh season of episode one beau Jeff
while he's on his insane drug trip he
imagines an entire life of what it would
have been like if he had ended up with
Charlotte married in Maine house in
Maine teenage daughter life and then at
the end of the trip Charlotte just says
you know Charlie gets this morose look
on her life in Bojack as what's robbed
she says that kicker line
oh I'm just thinking about what how nice
it would have been if you had chosen
this life Bojack wakes up in the rain in
a parking lot lying down in this sad
image and his phone is buzzing so yeah
episode 11 Bojack goes to tsuki right
outside of Santa Fe and it's a Charlotte
turquoise [ __ ] it's early [ __ ] surprise
Charlotte's Marion has two teenage kids
on the kids and instead of opening with
the normal theme which is done brilliant
that has a party of the of the black key
is it yeah oh Sh instead of opening with
the theme the opening sequence the
opening sequence of episode 11 is a fake
sitcom just showing photos of Charlotte
and her husband and kids and it's like
like a fake sitcom opening for Kyle and
the kids and the lyrics of the lyrics of
the song are things like Kyle they it's
like it's like sounds like it sounds
kind of full house like yeah it's like
full house it's like Kyle's the dad and
Charlotte's married to him we got a
couple of kids and there's nothing you
can do about it yes like as the song
progresses it gets more and more javi at
Bojack specifically yeah it's like it's
like who loves his wife and there's
nothing you can do about it it's like
seriously saying that yeah and then
Bojack tries to do something about it oh
yeah it goes real so like apparently
they were workshopping the idea that
Haddon apparently they were at some
point the writers room workshopping the
idea that Bojack would sleep with
Charlotte yeah but then it's like it's
almost even and I like what they did
because it's worse but better in a sense
it hits Bojack harder to be like no no
you don't even get a taste of that
fantasy you were building in your head
you don't even get the slightest hint of
that yeah I mean it's it's you don't
even get a lemon zest of it they sure
they have that kiss broke for a minute
there but then it's you know it's like
as so much more unhinged and lost in
that moment because yeah he's trying to
insist this yes come with me to LA be or
just come with me I know you feel this -
and then he doubles back instantly when
she puts up the sliced resistance
because it's like it's like Will
Arnett's playing it's like oh my god
you're saying bojack's starting to drown
yeah because it's the oboe Jax starting
to drown and he starts doubling down or
just just don't make me leave just
whatever just will go back to normal
like nothing happened just whatever you
do do not make me leave don't let me go
back to LA and then let me wow goes back
with I don't care where you go yeah yeah
he's wild-eyed at that moment I think
that's that's ultimately uh it's a it's
a more powerful choice for these yeah
cuz I it's it's just that little bit of
like it's a it's like it's that just
that little kiss but you totally by
Charlotte it's like yeah it's a yeah
it's like Bojack put the move on without
thinking Charlotte had like the tiniest
hint of a reaction or like out like him
well yeah you eat the way they animate
that it's like yeah it's a first second
there she's caught up in it and then she
realizes it's not even if it's that snap
like oh no she's caught up in it for a
second but then she doubles backs like
no like yeah that felt good first foot
second but I built a life yeah for 30
years I have built a marriage and a
house and a family and kids and I've
raised them to go to high school like
I'm you know and even though these
things you know even though like having
a family is difficult and funky it's
like this is and this is my life
yeah just and even like yeah the kiss
was someone I knew a long time ago is
like yeah it's got like that tiny
momentary thrill but that's like that's
that's not anything to drop your real
world for yeah exactly
man that and then because I it's
interesting too because like I saw
people online who are discussing the
show basically being like yeah but
Charlie was into it and I find it it's
like really interesting because it's
limited animation it's not into it but
it's like you know it's like a momentary
kind of autonomous reaction well I
bought it for a second it's like
it's you know it's he kisses her and for
a moment there it's like your brain your
brain gives out there's a little bit of
a thrill yeah so it's like you're not
launching in that moment then when she
when they come apart it's like whoa cuz
she's the one who pulls apart first
yeah it's like you I think they animated
that moment really well we could hit and
that was interesting to me just like the
fact that when you think about do your
mind in that in that situation I got
imagine you'd still wonder a little bit
yeah you know that it's not the way to
do yeah I mean it's it's interesting
because like it's a thing of just the
the workflow and how many people had to
be on board with like everyone's brain
had to sync up correctly the because
there had to be you know the showrunner
you know bob-waksberg the guy who
specifically wrote that episode of I
think was Joe Lawson everyone else in
the writers room they had to all be on
the same page for how exactly how much
and in what ways Charlotte reacted to
that kiss and by what degree then the
the storyboard artist for that sequence
of that episode had to get that down the
anime didn't team overseas had to get
that down like but but the end of it
several dozen people had to know by
millimeters how these two people moved
and then the actors had to play in this
specific way because Olivia Wilde has to
have like that that you know sound
reaction that vocalization so it's like
you know several dozen people had to all
be on one hundred-percent exactly the
same page to make it seem like this is
exactly how much Charlotte is reacting
to this kiss and by what degree and what
the subtext is and what that means and
how much she's going with and how much
she isn't that's several dozen people
now in live like in the live-action
movie it's the act you know the writer
has to determine what the ultimate
subtext is the director has to determine
how that's going to be play being key
and the actor have to confer
and you know and you know the editor has
to choose to take that that bet spits
that so I in a live-action setting up
met like on average like four people
have to be on that same page yeah four
people have to be synched up to how
that's gonna work at you know absolutely
whereas for animation it's several dozen
yeah that's that at the team that's such
a team and they all have to be on that
exact same page of what the what's going
on in this deers brain and that's well
and that's a kind of phenomenal to me
that that did not get so [ __ ] up or so
buckle well yeah because it cuz because
even so I mean even even with those four
people you know who would do it on like
a regular live-action movie it's still
in theory comes down more to the actors
in the very end yeah because they
control the movements and the voice
modulation boots like in an animated
environment there's one there's one us
actor and then there's X number there's
the board or the storyboard artists in
an X number and actual animators yeah
it's like your voice your noise
performance has to be on point but then
somebody else entirely has to do has to
manage the movements and manage you know
little nuances and that and then find a
way to marry them properly that's you
know you know when it's done right like
I like I think it was here it's it's
magic yeah it's it's with how dark it
gets it's [ __ ] black magic yeah some
it's some death leadership well and then
it gets I want oh man I I want to start
like a group of like dark wizards that
do slam poetry called The Death Eaters
oh I'm sorry
take that joke back it's okay it's okay
it sound that sound on the ether man
it's a space but and then he tells he
tells her daughter to go to bed and I
thought that was like yes over a moment
I was like okay so and then probably
Scotty teenage daughter named penny
penny 17 which is legal in in New Mexico
she's certain to let us all know because
of a few different
Bojack ends up when he escapes le and
basically he buys a boat to cover for
the fact that he's in New Mexico very
arbitrarily and so this boat it's a
parked in Charlotte's driveway and yet
this the family advice oh yeah just stay
as long as you want at beau Jack stays
there for like two months
like grossly overstaying his welcome but
you know the family clearly doesn't know
what to do in boat I kind of assimilate
Cindy then ends up like being this kind
of interloping surrogate and he gets
really you know he gets really close to
penny
Charlotte's teenage daughter who is in
the in the way in which they designed
this show it's like multiple species can
date inmate and their kids will just be
one species of the parent so it's like
beyond the visual metaphor some animal
some characters being animals it's
account produce so in the case so if son
has a lot of thumbs yeah so in the case
of of Charlotte and Kyle Charlotte
Sudhir Kyle's a human they have a son
named Tripp who looks a lot like Kyle
but has who trips a lot they have a son
named Kyle who's a human and then they
have a daughter named penny and Penny's
a deer but with kind of dark hair light
like tile they don't do hybrids so so
penny looks a lot like Charlotte
naturally so Bojack gets us like I've
assimilated into the family and
Boatwright gets assimilated into the
family and did you can tap at one point
taking a penny out to teach her to drive
because the other parents are busy from
then on out Ian's it's kind of like
getting involved in her life and and
becoming like a friend and he ends up
being her chaperone to prom and bonejack
so very irresponsible - yeah I guess
functional as well oh he's like a
horribly irresponsible dysfunctional
alcoholic and he should not be around
children yeah it's and I don't know how
how how you sort of receive some of that
but it's like you know he's he's on this
sabbatical and at first you're kind of
like yeah cool like you know you try to
drive and stuff but like them
time he spends around these kids he gets
way more sucked into their lives and he
should be so it's like he's yeah because
he's stuntin he's not the proper adult
to have around you know he's a 50 or 51
year old man and he's he's starting to
like very carelessly try and become an
adolescent again and regress while he's
with them it's kind of like it's kinda
like Kevin Spacey and American Beauty
well that was very I mean I guess I
guess maybe part of the point is that
you know there ultimately are bigger
fish to fry but I was very curious as to
what was gonna happen with her friend oh
yeah and a peach repeat repeat
yeah because Bojack because you know one
of the kids that one of like Penny's
friends is like sneaking alcohol in on a
flask and Bojack being the seasoned
alcoholic is like oh don't don't drink
red Bull and vodka you can get yourself
sick I'm gonna get you some bourbon
you're gonna cut it with water and that
way you don't get a hangover and so her
friend ends a drinking way too much and
like being absolutely out of her gourd
Bojack realizing I'm a 51 I'm a 51 year
old man with a bunch of 17 year olds and
I gave them alcohol and they're
absolutely [ __ ] up or this one girl is
absolutely [ __ ] up this is looking
terrible for me yeah he drops off he
drops off the I can't remember thing he
drops off the friend who's drunk at the
hospital and leaves this this kid Pete
repeat and the hole and his spine that
they it's good hey I'm Pete repeat there
because this is skidding so [ __ ] dark
and scary like is this girl going to die
and and it's good that they have PvP
there because he's he's that kid you you
knew in high school who had a nickname
and a thing that you know isn't really
true about him yeah he repeats whole
thing is that he says everything twice
but she only does once he only does once
in the whole episode you'd never
remember if he's done it always just
assumes he did he never really did yeah
and he does it once on a very like
flatline keeps on asserting that he's he
keeps on the serving like oh yeah that's
my thing that I say everything twice
which he he he
Oh an interesting thing repeat his voice
actors a guy named Jermaine Fowler who's
a really cool dude who if you ever see
him do stand-up in the LA area you'll
know it's him because he literally has
jean-michel basquiat hairdo oh wow yeah
he's a really cool dude yeah shouts out
to Jermaine Fowler he's [ __ ] rad all
right from Maryland president did you
this from heard the Baltimore area boo
so yeah and it's like we all knew that
kid in high school where it's like every
kid wants to be the kid with like the
thing the bit the gimmick this is my but
it's so forced and so so ridiculous
there's the loud ass cricket dude this
cricket is getting down with the dang
this cricket right I love your show I
feel like this cricket wants to let us
know his opinions on the show I've
actually been watching season two all
this week and I have things to say
theories about where the show will go in
the future we don't want we don't want
your input cricket got a [ __ ] why don't
you go bum food off the ants who
harvested all spring you are not liking
the fable I think so
by Aesop Rock oh oh
fables yeah dude Aesop that dude wrote
too many famous babes
dating of like you know what's going to
happen with Bojack you know visa be this
way to drunk out of her mind teenager
that he was supposed to be responsible
for so it's good that there's there's
that kid - kind of like balance out the
comedy for a bit yeah or balance out the
the balance it out with some comedy what
I also really like once they get to the
hospital I really like the way they
played him just because you can tell
that he's just not not really okay with
what he's being told yeah it's like
level of conflict was nice yeah like
very like very well played in meanwhile
I was like Bojack when he's really
trying to coach this kid as to like you
know you don't know where how where she
got the alcohol and your friend you know
we we left the dance early it
it's like Bojack gets really dark and he
feels like totally unlikable works like
yeah dude you're scaring this kid who's
in way over your way over his head
and you you you know and it's to clean
up your mess that you know clearly you
know and it's like you see the way the
mess of balls over the course of the
episode works like it's not necessarily
that it's like it's not like Bojack was
malicious it's just like he was so
wrapped up in his own [ __ ] of
wanting to like relive his adolescence
and this is prom and he just was not
watching how [ __ ] up this rule was
getting with the alcohol he's applied
her to replace the alcohol that would
that could have very well left her worse
off well because he's all focused on
penny
yeah he's focused on is all about
bonding with you know finding in with
Charlotte through penny yeah and so he
and really yeah and so it's like he go
he goes back to he goes back to the
house to drop penny off and penny has
you know developed like you know
something of us transferred schoolgirl
crush on Bojack saying you know you want
to do it I'm ready thinking she knows
what you know I know what I want and
Botox ain't no you don't you're a kid
you don't know what you want and penny
saying she knows what she's doing and
you know she's legal in the state she
hasn't had a touch of alcohol so
things on the up-and-up and it's like
your Bojack does the baseline decent
thing of saying go to bed well yeah I
mean there there is just the way they
play that struggle is nice and kind of
sophisticated this slice was a very very
intricately tune to exchange this
episode yeah I mean just that whole
progression especially when they get
home from prom is you know I mean this
is more sophisticated debate than you
would get in a lot of other shows I feel
like you know it's it's you know you can
feel how conflicted like you know you
get this something means that linking oh
this is you don't know what you want go
to bed like it's it you know that rings
is genuine but but it makes just as much
sense how it ends up later yeah so it's
like Denbo Jack ends up going back and
he hasn't going back and having that
interlude with Charlotte where there's
the kiss and all that stuff and then
crestfallen Bojack goes back to sleep on
his boat in the driveway and you know
penny kiddos back and he tells her to go
to bed but this time it's a different
thing where it's like it's a different
thing we're like you know boat I've just
got given the you know he just got told
off by Charlie he just got dismissed by
Charlotte so it's like now he's unmoored
and he's untethered and he doesn't have
he doesn't have something else to brace
himself again so he says again to penny
penny trying to trying to get at him
again and he says go to bed penny and he
goes back and do the the sleeping
quarters of his boat but he leaves the
door open it's almost like there's this
thing where it's like bow Jack he's
responsible for it but he doesn't want
to be responsible for it because he's at
that point he's too weak and he wants
some kind of validation because he just
lost it from Charlotte something he was
waiting on for 30 years
yeah and so because he didn't get that
validation he wants something to kind of
swoop him up and and make him feel you
know make him feel not shitty but he
knows how dangerous it'd be so he
doesn't he wants to
kind of undercut his own culpability so
instead of going for it he just resigns
himself to it which isn't just kind of
performative you can you know by leaving
the door open he literally and
figuratively left the door open for
penny to try and do [ __ ] yeah and and
sure enough Charlotte walks in then I
was hoping against hope should be
surprised but it's another one of those
moments was like no it's what you think
it is because that's what would happen
like like worst case scenario has gone
down yeah and it's and again it was very
fine-tuned it was very specific you know
there was a lot of talk that went into
specifically what clothes were gonna be
off what clothes were gonna be on what
situation or what position they were
gonna be in so when they see they're
mostly still 100% clothed yeah bojack's
on the bed penny standing next to the
bed and Penny's reaching at his bow tie
and it's just just just compromising
enough yeah exactly
when I think that's a good level for
that I think that was that was all it
needed to be yeah
and Charlotte just okay but I tried to
make it pass in me and then when he when
I told him all if he went for my [ __ ]
daughter oh the way she tells him off
like that shouts out to Olivia Wilde for
making me [ __ ] my pants not literally
but you know I in my soul Olivia Wilde
has got one of those voices worse like
like between her telling off Bojack at
the end of episode 11 of season two and
her response to Joaquin Phoenix in her
during the blind date thing it's like
yeah Olivia Wilde has like God Olivia
Wilde is the kind of actions where she
can put in her performance works like
you feel her whatever she says can
instantly like destroy a male habitat in
this life I guess I you know I'm always
for whatever reason I don't know why I
think I'd only ever seen her in like bit
parts on the house or something but like
you know ever Thomas here I'm like oh
well like you know yeah you got some
chops man like yeah like cuz I'd only
ever known her from just things you
don't associate with you know nuances I
guess you know it's like oh you were in
Tron Legacy which is more about the
Speck to go and the effects and stuff
than it is about performances or or you
are on yeah you know a medical drama
which is more about you know the
situation or procedure and you have to
be able to be good enough but you know
the emotional resonance of any one of
those shows is usually there's there's
usually sort of a particular scale those
will all play but as I've seen her in
more movies and even in stuff like this
I'm always you know kind of impressed
with with what she's doing so you know
and and and here is yeah that I didn't
[ __ ] myself but I was just sort of you
know stunned yeah you know because I
mean it's like that moment where you you
realize so it's like all throughout this
season from episode from episode 11 from
episode 11 of I guess maybe even before
that cuz there is an episode early on
season 1 of Bojack where you see
Charlotte and you know the last time
Charlotte and Bojack hung out with
Charlotte says I'm moving to Maine you
know I think la is kind of a tar pit I
I'm I want to get out of here and then
she says to beau jack is like hey if if
if you know when we first met herb
wasn't you know me and herb work
together would you have made a move and
project gets nervous and Charlotte says
I don't think you would because you know
deep down I think you it kind of a
coward and so like that's the last time
Bojack left with so it's like you know
so it's like bojack's been pining pining
for this woman since that moment an
incentive to prove his non cowardice
yeah so it's like you know now it's like
now there's this bull there's this kind
of unspoken belief working in bojack's
mind
oh the proof of whether or not I'm going
to be okay in my life is if I I finished
this unfinished business with Charlotte
yeah and complete that narrative this
was the thing this this external thing
is what the key and is what I have to
hold on to and it's yeah and that's that
ultimate thing because you know I think
everybody they're not just such a level
of intensity but I think everybody goes
there at some point when there's like
they think this is the thing that will
fix me or that will you know unlock a
major part of my problems is this
external thing I missed or I bungled or
forgot to do yeah and it's just there
it's rarely as ever that yeah this is
this is the the moat a pretty
devastating you should have loved that
yeah you know it's like this was my shot
at happiness and it's like no it's and
now or your shot at happiness you yes
like your shot at happiness is what you
do literally every day when you get out
of the bed it's your habit it's your
pattern
it's what you're what you what you
repeat doing it's not the one part of
your story of your life that you were
writing for yourself it's not that that
one o'clock point that you were supposed
to hit that you missed yeah so it's like
the center there's the central tension
throughout the show until like that
episodes like okay Bojack like there's a
reason we're seeing charlotte Bojack
needs to wrap up the charlotte thing or
find closure or resolution in his whole
charlotte thing and it's like it's like
yeah sure but the resolution he needed
to find in a charlotte thing was stop
searching for resolution in the
charlotte thing yeah exactly
trying to find resolution as charlotte
thing was going to just nuke it
charlotte thing so it's like the worst
possible scenario that could have
happened with this charlotte thing just
in terms of the relationship happens at
the end of episode 11 charlotte
literally says to him if you ever
contacted me or my family again I will
[ __ ] kill you yeah so there was there
was so much in that line yeah that was
that like I said I mean I was already
sort of just lost in that moment and
when she said that it was like a gut
punch
yeah like well
it's a very hats off man yeah my soul
still hurts
yeah that was a that was a sock to this
[ __ ] yeah and and I mean and and there's
go on
no on a different well it just on a
contrasting no you know it's like part
of the other thing too that I've come to
very much appreciate that I love is you
know the following episode you know
there's still you know there's still
things to be addressed and that whole
sequence where he saves Todd it was like
you know I really appreciated that
moment too because they have that whole
thing that again on maybe a lesser
inclined show or a different show could
have gone just more cheaply as like when
he's got him on the ladder and all the
improv Scientology people are like you
know well is this guy really your friend
you know he's all he ever does is
treating terribly and abuse you use you
and ruin your ideas and stuff like that
and it was sabotage you and that moment
they have together work where he just
kind of looks down it's like you can
tell he's he's aware and and you know is
he's aware of that he's you know
processing it in the moment but he just
says you know it's it's complicated like
it's hard to explain
yeah and it really does speak to I feel
like gonna let her show they would have
just he would have gotten angry or
something I'm gone back on the ship and
then yeah but it's like these they do
have an understanding they do have you
know yeah a true a true friendship in a
sense you know it's like as much as bow
Jack you know shits on Todd and you know
it's like Todd kind of like its
addressing the first season of like and
you kind of in a way that sort of like
shits on bow Jack where Todd says I
should just stop the excitement like
expecting you to be a good person so I
won't be hurt when you're not yeah and
that's like in Todd delivers that line
it's a bit of a mini wake-up call to bow
Jack yeah and it stays true to that you
know and and you get the sense that at
least you know Todd understands a bit of
what's yeah he lives with Bo Jack he
understands a bit about what's going on
in there yeah as I Todd says is at the
very beginning of this like the first
episode of this series and like Todd
says you know deep down who have a good
heart yeah so it's like
you know and then the show like
questions I like what is deep down does
deep is deep down a real thing yeah what
I mean orders deep diving a place where
people create for you know create just
because they then die and Alison Brie
character has another answer words you
know what matters is what you do yeah
and then there's and then there's that
bit of so it's interesting that there's
this whole like Scientology cult subtext
with the improv group that Todd gets
sucked into because there's this you
know as bowtie starts on this like faux
self self-improvement you know kick he
starts jogging badly and there's this
this BAM that was also great yeah
there's this baboon or this Gibbon
that's jogging up the same like street
of Laurel Canyon that Bojack lives on
like literally every episode yeah every
episode when you see bojack's house you
see that jogger and the jogger
eventually speaks and when the dog
speaks he's voiced by Jason Beghe or
desi who is a former Scientologists who
was in going clear
oh no way yeah he's the raspy dude that
does all the cop shows the raspy voice
okay and so it's like the very last bit
of the of the season is brilliant
because it makes it tells the difference
between it's the difference between it's
like there's this fundamental like core
statement at the core of the show of
Bojack horseman words saying
Bojack worked on a sitcom the thing is
we all grow up with TV and sitcoms that
give us a [ __ ] view of how life
works you know where things are succinct
and definite and finite and and they
have a beginning and a middle and an end
and and they have resolution and they
have core through lines that are easily
to wrap your head around and then the
show is saying no that's [ __ ] yeah
life is a series of life is tangental
yeah dirty and life is tangental and
dirty and messy and you know the light
ray and the universe doesn't point the
universe does not have a you know linear
moral compass there's no one making sure
that the status quo will be reinstated
at the end of it
yeah and at the end of the day you know
what are your status your life is a
matter of your patterns your life is not
your life is your habits your life isn't
some who you are some big deep down
identity that's built up over the course
of of you know plot points throughout
this season your life really is habits
you pick up and you cultivate your
develop so Bojack collapses because
jogging sucks and the Jason Beghe baboon
is leaning over and says it gets easier
but you got to do it every day yeah
that's the hard part but it gets easier
well that's and it cuts to a song called
a Baumgartner hey hey they're really
good these guys really nailed the
license music they do yeah like a
Richard Kelly yeah I think Bojack
horseman was buck shotgunning so much of
that it's a compressed period of time
you know I just finished watching this
yesterday you heard this morning room it
was it will leave you kind of shaky need
yeah so I'm still sort of sort of
processing and running on the software
as I say like coming down to it like
there's something really cool and we're
just talking about like Bojack and his
relationship like there's a very cool
thing with Bojack and and his girlfriend
at the beginning half of the of the
season with Wanda who's a network exec
that just wakes up from a 30-year coma
so she doesn't know who bojack's
story yeah and it's interesting like
Wanda's awesomely handled as a character
because it's late it almost like she she
starts out as you think oh she's waking
up from this coma so she's just this
kind of quirky you know Lisa Kudrow II
Phoebe s character you know she's got
the multicolored skirt she feels like
this Manic Pixie dream girl and then
it's like what ultimately would
ultimately help like breaks down the
relationship is not that Wanda is this
is this like flaky or or kind of like
wow what's the word is um she's not like
flaky and she's not not
yes she's not bubbly what breaks up
their relationship is the fact that like
she's a human being in kind of a mature
adult and she can't handle bojack's
dysfunctional [ __ ] yeah and she's not
gonna put up with it she learns to see
through the rose-colored glasses yeah
red flags yes there's that there's a
brilliant like there's an awesome
exchange what happens Bojack you didn't
know me then you fell in love with me
now you know me and then feet lawanda
has that that line it it's funny when
you look at somebody through
rose-colored glasses all the red flags
just look like flag yeah well that's
enemy that's another that's another
scene that's handled so nicely because
it's like it starts out as a light scene
and then it escalates into an argument
in a very natural way it's like just as
buttons get get pushed under and then
they start to confront each other over
his sort of blatant disrespect for her
work yeah which is also his own work
which is also yeah his own or it's like
his just is like his his frustration
with his life he can only voice that in
[ __ ] on something that is external
to him yeah I wanna say and at the same
time it's like you don't get to [ __ ] on
this you know just because you know
network execs that people bring this in
it's like you are a participant yeah you
know you built your whole life on that
yeah exactly so you don't get to just
turn your nose up at it because you you
know realize the garbage yeah it's like
and this season kind of goes into every
every characters kind of you know
general dysfunction like you know
there's a whole there's this whole thing
where it's like the Alison Brie
character Diane she has a big battle
that she ultimately loses and she's just
kind of a mess at the end of it oh yeah
yeah yeah that whole double montage
where she is perpetually like laying
contorted on the floor and just a pile
of pizza and pile of pizza and beer and
beer while mr. peanut butter does the
show and is loved and adored yeah
and it's well now the wholesome
with keegan-michael key yeah the who
plays like the the philanthropist that
want some that wants Diane to come to a
war-torn Albania esto yeah they should
call Cordova to cover him in his like
philanthropic band the grandstanding
yeah
you know what while Bojack kind of goes
takes all of his his dissatisfaction he
externalizes it in his way with
relationships with people like when
Diane externalizes all of her
dissatisfaction it goes in to kind of a
political thing like she wants you
because she feels like she's she's kind
of a mess in herself and in her own life
she needs to go to Cordova and feel like
she's doing important work that's
helping the world or making it a better
place in some capacity or she needs too
much after that yeah crushed yeah it's
like she needs to Diane feels you know
it's like because my life feels
dissatisfactory and messy and in
shambles I need to go fix the world and
then if I fix the world then my life
will be okay yeah it's like I've done
something worthwhile the world yeah feel
fulfilled and all the results I'll feel
like my life has meaning and Worth and
value but even that turns out to be just
a pit of more frustration well yeah and
then you know that character - I was
just yeah st. Claire
he basically like you know she's
literally started to point out that that
guy's kind of full of [ __ ] - just
everybody's everybody is sort of
everybody all the people around her sort
of posturing and looking for attention
and looking to be a grand eyes ya know
you know these like just flagrantly kind
of gross in disrespectful ways yeah
exactly yeah and it's like her
intentions are always always seem you
know good-hearted genuine noble and pure
but it's like she comes up against the
fact that the world does not build sis
to really sustain you know big
meaningful positive change she tries to
take down and it's like they do an
episode that's focusing on Diane works
like you know of course it's the Diane
episode is more about taking down a
monster in this there's this um this
lake this variety show host this
old-timer ayat II host a variety show
host voiced by Philip Baker hall
named Hank HIPAA populace so happy they
got him yeah because he's perfect well I
was just wasn't expecting yeah that's
like Hank HIPAA propolis is a you know
she just mentions off-the-cuff in a
public space about like all these like
historical allegations about Inka
poplars doing something scandalous to
his assistants former assistants and
when she says that suddenly it's like
everyone must be a Ligurian yet so Cosby
allegory and when she says that everyone
jumps on her so go what have you got
hurt against Hank in pavakah Liz and
then just like she has to defend herself
by going on the attack against HIPPA
populace was like that's not what she
mentions just like saying oh yeah like
so many celebrities have had like really
gross accusations against them and she
names real ones
yeah even people like Bill Murray who
are still just so loved and adored by
the fans face and so to say people jump
on it's like what do you got against
Hank HIPAA propolis and so it's like now
she has to to defend and protect herself
from being attacked she has to throw in
and fight the the ongoing mired and
stymied fight against Hank HIPAA
populace which ends up all being for not
yeah just because you know it's like the
you know the the bigwig she goes to
manatee fair which is run by literal
manatee manatee to write the expose on
Hank F of propolis and then they decide
oh yeah these you know these kinds of
articles don't sell magazines and the
same thing big conglomerate company that
runs you know Hank hippopotamuses
Network dance yeah that has hanky baba
palaces show ahead and keep dance also
owns manatee fair so it's like sounds
like then it's like you know Cordoba
turned out to be a bust because you know
the guys who his work with Sebastian st.
Clair Sebastian st. Clair turned out to
be a [ __ ] charlatan who was in it for
his own narcissistic [ __ ] so then
taking down Hank hit a populist ended up
being for not so it's like finding your
meaning and creating a better world
around you and fighting evil and you
know or fighting for good or helping the
downtrodden even that ends up not
working yeah I think there's something
kind of brilliant at the core
the show and I think what really works
is the fact that yeah there's nothing
working together really well that
everyone in the show is so dysfunctional
yeah everyone in the show has a big
issue everyone's struggling everyone's
broken everyone doesn't work and I think
it really works at half the characters
are animals because it basically creates
this visual metaphor of like you know
when you see an animal doing something
wrong or doing something that is not how
that person is supposed to act or behave
you think you don't think oh what's
wrong with them you just think oh yeah
you know that's just what they do they
don't know better yeah and so when you
see a whole world where everyone has
those tendencies you know it's like
raccoon people are digging in the trash
outside of a diner or you know or you
know there's a you know just just a
little quirky things like but it's
always throwing doors into bird people
yeah doors are always being slanted to
bird people there's like one there's
like one PA on the on solidiers game
show that's always getting a door to
slam through first when you see a bunch
of we see a bunch of animal people
acting like animals it kind of sets you
up to get into this headspace of yeah
these are people and they're sentient
but there's still something about them
where it's like they can't quite help
themselves there's still something so
kind of vulnerable and just kind of
working off of baser instincts at the
core of everybody well I think that's I
think that's the thing that that just in
the general scheme of life I think
that's a kind of a cogent metaphor
because we do just as the specie is like
to pretend that we're so far removed
from as our superior intellect separates
us from the animals but it's like you
know at the core of everything it seems
at the core of all problems we're
struggling with some very simple and
very animal animal things yes like
instinctually listed mean we can't get
we can't get over like an insecurity
about an animalistic need like you know
even something that seems like it's a
little bit higher like you know we think
we're not gonna get validated we think
we're not gonna be loved we think we're
not going to be you know appreciated or
respected yeah
but it's still you know it's still is
sort of a primitive thing and that's why
I sort of start sometimes feel like you
know maybe this this version of the
software this superior intellect is
still in something since my beta of yeah
of an infancy or an adolescence where
it's like we still haven't gotten past
certain based instincts and certain base
desires and certain just just base
problems the whole of the human race is
like like Holden Caulfield like very
smart and very intelligent and very
astute but just not not emotionally
intelligent enough to deal yeah exactly
and and you know especially sighted it
is not exactly encouraging of that are
conducive to that ya know it's like
figuring your [ __ ] out in the stage
really hard Jim I gotta appreciate the
show and you know this is you know this
is like a way to articulate that's
already come to me a few times or it's
like a cartoon about a horse on the
Internet is actually the most humanistic
show on TV right now yeah this web
cartoon about a horse
is the most humanistic TV show and
running currently can't think of any
better way to say that's why I said it
twice why I said it twice
don't even tell it don't even say
anything we told you how about what what
we told you all about twice about twice
so yeah I'm you down for season three oh
hell yeah I'm down for as many seasons
as as can be yeah I mean you know it's
it's you know I mean and for as much as
we're going into into great detail about
the deeper the more affecting and in
deep refer to the show it's also a lot
of fun oh yeah like you know it's
there's a lot of humor and there a lot
of really fun and enjoyable characters
yeah like um Todd builds his own
Disneyland and just the it's a visual
care it's terrifying in made out of like
just strip together balsa wood with this
giant animatronic Todd at the center of
that's just this horrible googly eyed
mutant monstrosity
Todd's Disneyland is and I just
love like those little tiny moments
where it comes back kind of we're just
people went to Todd's Disneyland yeah
hey
Charlotte's family went to Todd's Disney
like or how come it's like we mentioned
earlier it's like the show is like very
confident in being weird yeah and I
don't think anything crest is that quite
as much as Vincent adult men yeah where
is he he was kind of killed off in this
season mrs. Altmann so Kat so Princess
Carolyne in season 1 goes on the rebound
and she dates and she's like she says I
need to date a real adult like that guy
over there and she gestures across the
bar where there is clearly three little
kids stacked on top of each other in a
trench coat who's you know the top kid
that speaks for the the stack is voiced
by Alison Brie I think oh really yeah
well I mean you know most most mentally
just our three kids in a trench coat
yeah so it's like in Bojack is the only
one who recognizes innocent adult men as
being three little kids everyone else
just talks about what a great guide
innocent is and how cool he is well in
that that whole that hope is that where
they're doing the the I don't know how
to describe or draw a touchdown that
situation but basically where he's like
pulling double-duty yeah cuz Princess
Carolyne in season two sees the the top
kid out of costume on the street and
then thinks oh my god Vincent has a son
and so the kid shows that my princess
Carolyn's apartment and has to swap and
get and does like that sitcom thing of
like you know Princess Carolyne has to
be out of the room so the kid can swap
between being the son and being within
senses and you always have Nicks and
here's what I think
cuz this this show actually kind of left
it open as to whether or not we're
seeing Ben basically there's this kind
of like you could very much read it as
Vincent actually is an adult and the
reason only Bojack sees it or okay one
reading is
yeah bojay is the only person that sees
Vincent as a child in adult clothing
because Bojack is stunted and he himself
as a child in adults garb here so that's
one two but Vincent is actually an adult
but Bojack is seeing Vincent as a little
kid because that's basically a
projection of his insecurities because
Bojack is 50 and he he can't stand to
see someone who is actually seemingly
happy and successful with their lives of
Bojack so when we see Vincent we're
actually seeing bojack's interpretation
of him which is you know his
frustrations manifested seeing you know
Vincent as a charlatan it's like how can
this guy be happy and have his [ __ ]
together he must be faking it so ergo
I'm going to say he's an L and he's
younger than me and more more you know
psychologically successful than me ergo
I'm going to see him as a little kid and
a charlatan so with those two thing that
works but until because because he's not
there for that other episode yeah he's
not there for that part of that episode
he's not there for that part of that
episode but then there are things like
you know you see Vincent on the phone
alone in an office still dressed up as
full Vincent somehow and like they were
in the bar so it's like clearly if these
kids are living their life this double
life as being like a collective adults
they're really really committed it's
really good at it one of the things that
is that episode is that scene progress
where it where it keeps switching back
and forth making it at least making it
appear very much like the kid is just
jump is doing double do jump back forth
between being the son and being Vincent
it gets so wacky and it's so prolonged
that after a while is like I I don't
know what to think anymore yeah it's
like are they actually going to like I
was expecting a reveal of like yeah
because there is a point where it's like
the kid fakes like this the stack of
kids so the top kid goes off and does
the Sun while the bottom two kids who
you never see are still in the trench
coat with apparently a bowling ball and
a towel over it pretending to be
Vincent's head so I was thinking I'm
half expected I was half expecting
you're gonna do a reveal where there
actually is a Vincent yeah inside to try
while the kid is there and all this time
Vincent is literally both like Vincent
literally is a real adult and that
literally really is this side yeah yeah
and then Vincent pops back later for
just like a cutaway joke where he's in
his office again being like met like in
a meeting yeah so it's like I don't know
if we've seen the last of Vincent adult
'men or not I hope we have not seen the
last just do I don't know why that that
gag just generally the three kids in a
trench coat just really tickles me for
some reason
yeah but ya know I really hope that we
get some more of that character and
perhaps learn kitna like what is because
he seems so lumpy inside the trench coat
so it's like is this mutant man maybe he
just has maybe he has that that syndrome
where your where your belly is all lumpy
and kind of off to the side yeah exactly
and then he's just got really stuff you
like
with he still has a broom for one hand
well maybe he lost his hand in the war
in the war whatever war the war in
Cordoba
yeah the season is darker it's deeper
it's weirder it's funnier than the first
season was and I love the first season
buts like yeah this season just kind of
dials everything from the last season up
to 11 and continues it in a pretty great
way well yeah I mean it
the you know jumping from season 1 to
season 2 and the progression of
especially Bojack as a character it's
like the tones of the seasons make sense
next to each other but you can also sort
of make the argument that it's it seems
like season 2 it's like okay now we
really know what the what we're doing
with this show and now we can really own
that and so it comes off as very smooth
either way and I'm I'm you know just a
little bit curious as to how how much
foresight there was you know yeah for
that what I'm interested in is okay so
the last episode of season 1 really set
up what season 2 was going to be about
projects in the Secretary of movie so
he's going to have to do it
he's got the dream role he always wanted
now
he's going to have to not [ __ ] that up
yeah he knows that he's you know still
like you know he knows that he's buying
for what happened you know wanting to
wrap up whatever that story in his brain
is with Charlotte so you know he's going
to have to hit up Charlotte and and see
where that goes you know yeah so it's
like you know the the oh and then
there's the Diane is after all the
awkwardness that happens between them in
the first season Diane is now the
character consultant working on the
Secretariat movie yeah so it's like
plowing forward from the first season
into the second there's so much already
set up we know where season two is gonna
go yeah
season three based on season two season
two is just like Bojack feels so much
more adrift he has no more story to wrap
up he has no more narrative it's like no
now [ __ ] you have to actually
sit down and rebuild your habits and
make a real life for you instead of you
gotta read the next you can't go back
and revise the old one yeah you have to
jump into the great unknown and there's
just the option of this possible there's
just this possible play in broad oh yeah
his on Broadway off-broadway there's
just insane awesome Broadway yeah
there's just this possible play that
he's being asked to do with somebody
named Jill pill from apparently another
show he did other than the sitcom
universe and around he was famous for
which we've never heard of before this
Jill pill kefir she hasn't been seen or
heard in any other episode one he even
has to do a memory jog yeah so this must
have been a while ago yeah so there's
apparently a Joe kilowatts him in to
play in New York that he's possibly
going to do and then there's a imagine
he will do it yeah I imagine they will
do it too we will see Bojack on the
stage yeah so it was just like you know
even more hardcore for an actor you know
you know there's there I imagine he'll
use that as a very heavy tool for
emotional ah yeah you know so was like
we don't really quite get what the the
big thrust is it's like now he's got
some understanding of what he can do
that makes him feel good that
feel valuable that makes it feel nice
not terrible ISM actually being a good
friend to Todd I'm actually caring for
somebody other than himself yeah so I
don't know it's interesting I'm I'm
really down I'm really excited to see
where this this show goes when I'm
interested to see how they can you know
change that dynamic you know or at least
you know I'm sure it won't be a smooth
change but yeah yeah bojack's I'm trying
to be a better friend of Todd yes it's
gonna be strange yeah well yeah I know
I'm definitely I I cannot wait for the
next for the next season yeah well
you're gonna have to wait just gonna be
here yeah I know it's alright that's the
thing is that thing's hard about binge
watching is instead of instead of
watching the instead of watching the
show over the course of three months and
then only having to wait nine months you
watched the show over the course of a
few days to a few weeks or just one
sitting if you're insane
yeah has any wait a year I guess that
gives you a better chance to miss it
yeah yes it revisit yeah
I cannot believe because it's like it
feels like yesterday like I was watching
the first season being like this show is
amazing and I want more of it and I was
like oh my god I got more of it as it
were and it was kind of exactly what you
wanted yeah it's everything that I was
ever wanted there are some really
interesting refrains that to sleep the
show was actually very dense just like
oh yeah how many times does Bojack say
what are you doing here which is like
this a big key line that he keeps on
screwing up on the secretary movie what
he's on camera but later on it's like he
keeps on saying it to people in real
life and when he says it it's like it
has all the gravitas in the moroseness
that he's supposed to have on camera
yeah well I mean that look I think he
says it to penny right before things
really come to a head like she's on his
boat and he shows up he's like what are
you doing oh wow yeah that's well that's
of defining a struggle of the whole
Secretariat's subplot is like getting
getting all those awful emotions you
know are there
to come out to come out when when
wouldn't need them - yeah but in to keep
them at bay your daily life but do you
get them to come out when you need them
on camera yeah but not let them [ __ ] you
up anymore which is you know I imagine
the defining struggle of the traumatic
Hector England yeah yeah because it's
like you know I mean it's not said
outright but it's very clear Bojack is
attracted to the secretary role because
it seems to encapsulate all the ugliness
he desperately need wants to get out of
himself
oh yeah well I mean it's also you know I
hear yeah but then it's like well how do
you do that role without just falling so
far into that pit of all that ugliness
that you you can't even manage in your
day-to-day life how are you gonna do
that on the job yeah exactly
well you know they just see gee yeah is
your city jeweller and this fix a new
post GUI Bo tank or subs heard something
post stub horse tank we plowed through
man yeah yeah I got like a battering ram
yeah so not a lot of digression OTT a
lot of baby fat on this one yeah this
was a lean mean Bojack machine lean mean
Bojack machine quick something frivolous
elephant elephant inflated place.you
inflates you frankest
biggest Lancaster oh hey guys um
downtown branch on Brown
why both sides are witnessing come
marching and marching and remember kids
stay dang